This is Jocko podcast number nine with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Perhaps I stabbed our savior in his sacred helpless side,
yet have called his name and blessing when an after times I died
through the travail of the ages,
midst the pomp and toil of war.
Have I fought and strove and perished countless times upon this star,
I have sinned and I have suffered,
played the hero and the nave fought for belly shame or country and for each have
found a grave.
So as through a glass darkly,
the age long strife,
I see where I fought in many guises,
many names,
but always me.
So forever in the future shall I battle as of your dying to be born a fighter
but to die again once more.
And that is a poem by General George S.
Patton.
And
I've been thinking about the podcast and about the direction and about the
things and about what we talk about and what I talk about.
And I was actually had been looking for a,
for a nonmilitary book,
for a book that talks about the same kind of things that I think about.
But it's not about war because there's a very small population that are engaged
in war,
in real war.
So I've been looking for a book and I've,
and I've got a bunch of books and books that I enjoy and books that I like and
I've been looking for a,
uh,
a good book that is not a war book.
And I had some close ones and maybe they'll make the cut,
but,
but we're not there yet
because,
because quite simply war is at another level.
It's not better and it's not a good thing and I don't worship war,
but it is in fact the ultimate human struggle.
Yeah.
And as Judge Holden
in the book,
Blood Meridian puts it.
This is the nature of war.
Who stake is at once the game and via authority and the justification.
Yeah.
Scene.
So war is the truest form of divination.
It is.
The testing of one's will and the will of another within that larger we'll,
which because it binds them is therefore forced to select
wars.
The ultimate game.
Because war is at last a forcing of the unity of existence.
War Is God.
Now I'm going to tell you I'm not going to go into blood meridian tonight.
Blood Meridian,
half talked about it on a couple occasions and one day we will,
and it's probably going to take multiple shows and it's going to take research
but that is a heavy heavy book that is thick with content and meaning and words
that are powerful
and that's it.
Tiny slice of blood meridian and we will get to it at some point and I actually
get,
you know people are always like,
hey do blood Maruti and do blood money.
Cause there's a lot of people that take a lot of information,
a lot of meaning from that book.
But I am not ready yet.
I'm not.
Do you know that's going to take,
and it's the same thing with Shakespeare.
People are like hey,
when are you going to do the Bard?
And it's the same thing.
I want to be fully prepared and I'm either going to to through,
maybe I won't be fully prepared to do the whole thing,
but maybe we'll take chunks of blood meridian.
Some chunks is Shakespeare and start to try and digest them because those are
big meals now.
That's why,
you know,
that's why we're not talking about a business book tonight.
That's why we're not talking about a business leader.
That's why we're not talking about a sports leader.
That's when I,
we're not talking about,
uh,
a public figure that had to struggle through whatever to get to the top of the
mountain that they were climbing or mountain climber.
We're not talking about that.
We're talking about war.
And
like I said,
war is not God.
Like judge Holden describes you in blood Meridian,
but it certainly is a powerful force in it.
Certainly is the ultimate struggle,
the ultimate struggle for life against other humans that want to end your life.
And that's it.
Which brings us to patent.
And that poem,
you know,
obviously in Patton's mind
he was a warrior before,
over and over again.
Yeah.
He thought he was reincarnated.
Reincarnate,
like,
well was a soldier for Caesar for hundreds and thousands of years.
Yeah.
And
before I do jump into pattern,
I do the tankers,
the tankers up the world that the u s military,
we worked with the [inaudible],
the First Brigade,
first armor division in Ramadi,
Iraq in 2006 the ready first and
the techs,
the 68 ton Abrams main battle tank with a giant turbine engine grinding the
street apart as they come to support and rescue and save
the seals,
which they did over and over again
and there was no
better sound in the world.
Then those tanks firing up their engines and putting main gun rounds in
buildings to kill bad guys and protect American troops.
And we heard a lot about patents while we were working with the 180 because the
guy is the kind of the foremost tanker.
And even me,
I grew up with patents because the George See Scott movie was released when I
was a kid and to this day I remember watching that for the first time and being,
you know,
Austrac my patent and when you stick your hand into a bunch of Goo that a moment
ago was your best friend's face,
then you'll know what to do.
Okay.
That's all.
And so that was just a,
that's how I grew up.
I mean,
I grew up,
I watched that movie so many times.
I can't even remember.
Do you still watch it?
We watched it in Ramadi.
We watched in Ramadi what?
Just to get fired up
and in.
It is a great movie.
But let's talk about the real Patton,
who actually in many ways was more colorful and more charismatic and really
larger than life in real life.
Then George C.
Dot.
Scott and the movie could make him out to be.
Hmm.
I read that he would,
when he'd talk and stuff,
he'd swear a lot of you use a lot of profanity,
but he,
he did that on purpose.
He did it like to,
to,
to send a message or to get his guys fired up.
But in regular conversation he didn't really know.
He's
a,
he's a mysterious guy with a lot of different facets to them.
So I'm going to kick this off.
So we're going to the book George S.
Patton War is,
I knew it
and,
uh,
interestingly,
this book was given to me by Leif Leif Babin who wrote extreme ownership with me
and who served with me and Ramadi and is one of my brothers.
So
general order number 18,
this is from patent to his troops.
Soldiers of the seventh army,
born at sea,
baptized in blood and crowned with victory.
In the course of 38 days of incessant battle and unceasing labor,
you have added a glorious chapter two,
the history of war,
pit it against the best Germans and Italians could offer you have been
unfailingly successful.
The rapidity of your dash,
which culminated in the capture of Palermo,
was equaled by the dog,
had tenacity with which you stormed cornea and captured Messina.
Okay?
Every man in the army deserves equal credit.
The enduring valor of the infantry and the input impetus ferocity of the tanks
were matched by the tire clamor of are destroying guns.
The engineer's perform prodigies and the construction and maintenance of
impossible rolls over impassable country.
The services of maintenance supply performed a miracle.
The signal correlate over 10,000 miles of wire and the medical department
evacuated and care for our sick and wounded on all occasions.
The navy has given generous and gallant support throughout the operation.
Our air has kept the sky clear,
entirely actually supported the operation of the ground troops.
Okay.
As a result of this combined effort,
you have killed or captured 113,350 enemy troops.
You've destroyed 265 of his tanks,
2,324 vehicles and 1,162 large guns.
And in addition,
you have collected a massive military booty running to the hundreds of tons,
but your victory has a significance be above and beyond.
It's physical aspect.
You have destroyed the prestige of the enemy.
The president of the United States,
the secretary of war,
the chief of staff,
General Eisenhower,
General Alexander,
General Montgomery have all congratulated you.
Your fame shall never die.
Gs Patent Junior,
lieutenant general US army commanding.
Okay,
so you were talking about getting fired up and what he would do to get fired to
get people fired up.
Very habit.
Yeah.
Obviously a very skilled writer with great command of the language.
Can you even imagine what you'd feel like hearing that address to you and your,
your people when you and your troops,
you and your brothers?
Yeah.
A little bit about patent.
Few military figures in history have laid siege to the public imagination.
More relentless leaving George S.
Patton Jr half a century after his exploits in North Africa on Sicily and across
occupied Europe.
His name still evokes the dash and Briova Cavalry cavalry charge.
He is widely considered the best field commander in the American Army of World
War Two and he is certainly one of the,
one of the most feared by the Germans who paid him the compliment before
Normandy of massing defenses against a nonexistent army patent group by V e day
in 1945 he commanded 18 divisions and 540,000 soldiers,
uh,
force comparable to the size of the American military at its peak in Vietnam,
the New York Times described,
declared in his obituary history is reached out and embrace general George
Patton.
His place is secure.
He was not a man of peace.
Oh Man.
Of Peace.
He was not.
But his legacy clearly transcends his military conquest.
He was complex and contradictory,
larger than life and yet all too human.
It is the patent paradox that trans fixes,
and this is something that we've talked about before on this podcast and it's
something that I talk about all the time and that is people's strengths can be
their weaknesses.
And you get a guy like patent who's hyper aggressive and that actually ends up
being a negative in some cases.
Even though it's extremely positive and others,
back to the book,
a warlord fighting in the name of democracy,
he was also an unrepentant Eris aristocratic snob.
So this is a guy that,
and they talk about this some more,
but a guy that was like proud of soldiers almost to a fault he revered soldiers
and yet he's the rest of crap.
[inaudible]
his devotion to common soldiers bordered on reverence,
yet is slapping of two enlisted men,
nearly caused him to sit out the war in disgrace.
And we'll get into that a little bit more.
He exuded confidence and relentless,
relentless certitude.
In truth,
he was insecure and often confused.
He was well read,
fluent in French.
And as a wealthy,
as a wealthy child of privilege and the husband of an heiress at home and
society's most fashionable salons,
he could also be crude,
rude,
and plain foolish.
His humility seemed heartfelt,
yet he acknowledged an overdeveloped personal ambition.
And once confessed,
I don't like the dirt at all except as a means to fame.
So I said,
this guy has a complex guy.
This isn't a salt of the Earth David Hackworth Guy.
You never got that from him.
You never got it from like a guy like Hackworth that he had any sort of quest
for glory.
He just to complete opposite.
And that's why patent for me is,
uh,
is not a pure figure.
You know,
not that I would really say that I can think of any pure fingers,
but he's definitely a very faulted leader and which makes it good to learn from.
And he had someone May,
I mean,
obviously I should,
I'm here I am
a complete idiot losers city here calling,
uh,
you know,
General George Askpat.
George says pat and say he's faulted leader,
so don't get me,
don't get me wrong here.
Yeah,
the guy was unbelievably
powerful leader,
an incredible leader and incredible tactician and strategist,
but it is very clear that he had some of those dichotomies that when a little
bit too far in one way or the other
as a warrior,
back to the book as a warrior,
his fundamental prescription for waging war involved the violent attacks
everywhere with everything.
Yet he considered the carpet bomb bombing of German cities to be barbaric,
useless and statistic.
So that's,
that's a contradiction.
Don't hear very much about them.
And here's how you seen by the higher ups a little bit.
Eisenhower who once referred to Patton as this mentally unbalanced officer also
told George Marshall Patent is a problem child.
But he is great.
He is a great fighting leader in pursuit and exploitation.
A division commander describe the general as invaluable and war,
but a disturbing element in times of peace and to that pattern was flattered.
But perhaps the epitaph you would treasure most came from one of his soldiers
before the allied invasion of France.
Here was a man for whom you would go to hell and back so clearly to his troops.
They held him in very high regard
quote from Patton,
may God have mercy on my enemies,
they will need it.
That's,
that's the kind of thing that when he says people,
you know,
the front line troops are going to hear that and say,
yes,
we are ready to roll.
Uh,
he also said leadership is a thing that winds battles.
I have it,
but I'll be damned if I can define it.
In patents career,
we see certain trademarks are relentless aggression and faith in the offensive
and uncanny instinct for enemy intentions and disposition.
Common theme that we talk about all the time being on offense,
being aggressive and patent was an absolute probably.
I think he's probably the most aggressive of the people that we've talked about
and I've pretty much,
I think of anyone I've ever heard of
and Nico was a little bit negative and we see to the creeping arrogance,
the Hubris which would cost the American army so dearly in Vietnam,
summing up the achievements of his troops in crushing the German counter attack
of December,
1944 patent with ponderable pride claims to have moved farther and faster and
engage more divisions in less time than any other army in the history of the
United States.
Possibly in the history of the world.
No country can stand against such an army.
This smug pride,
the disease of victory and I love that.
That's a,
that's a little something we should all remember the disease of victory.
Victory,
supposed to be all positive,
but guess what?
There's something called the disease of victory.
Back to the book.
This disease of victory would rot the army from within leading future commanders
to underestimate their enemies and overestimate their own battlefield prowess.
Tragically,
the only antidote to this disease of victory would be the humiliation of defeat.
We see that sometimes in sports a lot and we see it in sports.
We see it in business.
Sometimes people need to get humbled and when they get humbled,
they get arrogant from the victories and then they get humbled and they get back
in the game and they realize what they have to do to win
back to the book.
His passion from military life ran so deep that he considered it as natural for
me to be a soldier as to breathe.
War He claimed is the only place where a man really live.
This
beyond a keen interest in technological developments of armored vehicles and
airplanes,
he retained a near fanatical belief and the importance of being mentally and
physically ready to fight.
Even in war wary,
1920s he admonished junior officers,
you must school yourself to savagery.
And speaking of savagery,
this is the the slaps.
When he slapped these young enlisted troopers,
the infamous
heard round the world patents memoir gives the episode short shrift,
but it nearly wrecked his life in early August while visiting wounded troops on
Sicily,
the commander cuff to soldier who had been diagnosed as suffering from battle
fatigue patent called cowardice.
Further examination revealed the man had malaria and dysentery.
A week later patent repeated his behavior with another soldier and this time
made motions to draw his pistol as if to shoot the wretch.
Okay.
Pat and publicly apologized,
but remained privately unrepentant had other officers had the courage to do
likewise.
He wrote the shameful use of battle fatigue as an excuse for cowardice would
have been infinitely reduced.
Okay,
so that was a significant incident.
Had He,
you know,
he publicly apologized,
but he obviously didn't really mean that he felt he had done the right thing,
but still there was much glory to be one patents exploit in the battle of the
bulge abruptly wheeling his army around and driving 100 miles to the ICR dens to
hit the Germans in the flank with 17 divisions remains among the most storied
campaigns in modern warfare.
And then after the war as
Europe was now almost an occupied state,
many places.
And as
it has,
people talked about Patton being good for war but not being good for peace.
And that turned out to be pretty accurate,
no longer able to Adak.
He indeed became bullies.
Patent was arrogant,
defiant
and erratic as the summer of 1945 past.
And that's kind of the intro on patent.
Now,
going back now to the beginning of the war,
and
his first one of his early journal entries,
he says,
have been giving everyone a simplified directive of war use steam roller
strategy that is make up your mind on course and direction of action and stick
to it.
But in tactics,
do not steamroller attack weakness,
hold them by the nose and kicked him in the pants.
This is something that we talk about all the time.
It's,
it's,
it's flanking people.
It's not keeping,
not going into their strengths and keep attacking their strengths.
Know you,
you attack their strengths to keep them occupied,
but then you come around to the flank,
you know,
it's in Jujitsu,
you attack the arm and you get the knack or your attack the neck,
and you get the arm in combat.
It's flanking.
That's what it is.
And he was a master of this and pushed it very,
very hard.
Now
we can get into
a little bit more of his,
what he says are his reflections and suggestions.
And in this book,
if you,
if you do end up getting this book,
uh,
I'm basically skipping the war part.
The,
the,
the entire book is about what he did and how he did it.
And I'm skipping that,
and I've said this before because I liked to know about what they did and how
they did it because that is important.
But I like to know why they did it and what they were thinking and what
principles they were falling in this book.
Beautiful.
He breaks it down again,
it's written by him,
but it breaks down what he was thinking,
why he did take these actions and what his strategies and tactics were.
And this is great because he starts off saying something that's very similar to
what Lafe and I say in the beginning of our book,
which is like we didn't invent this stuff.
So here's general George Askpat and saying the same thing.
Probably there is nothing original in what I shall now put down because war is
an ancient subject and I,
an ancient man have studied and practiced it for over 40 years.
So what appears to me as original fought may say,
maybe simply subconscious memories.
So he's saying I didn't necessarily think of all this.
Then Lafe and I in the beginning of our books say the same thing
concerning the soldier.
The soldier is the army.
No Army is better than its soldiers.
The soldier is also a citizen.
In fact,
the highest obligation and privilege of citizenship is that a bearing arms for
one's country.
Hence it is a privilege to be a soldier,
a good soldier,
to be a good soldier.
A man must have discipline,
self respect,
pride in his unit and his country,
a high sense of duty and obligation to his comrades and to his superiors and
self confidence.
Born of demonstrated ability.
His number one
characteristic was which should come as no surprise there has been and is now a
great deal of talk about discipline but few people in or out of the army know
what it is or why it is necessary.
Okay.
No sane man is unafraid in battle but discipline produces in him a form of
vicarious courage,
which with his manhood makes for victory.
Self respect grows directly from discipline,
self confidence.
The greatest military virtue results from the demonstrated ability derived from
the acquisition of all the preceding qualities and from the,
from exercise in the use of weapons.
So self confidence comes from practice and skill and that's derived from
discipline.
Discipline is clearly a subject we talk about quite a bit and its importance in
the military is
cannot be overstated.
It really can't be.
And I would go so far as to tell you that disciplines importance in life cannot
be overstated.
The root of all good characteristics is the discipline.
Battles are won by fire and by movement.
The purpose of movement is to get the fire in a more advantageous place to play
on the enemy.
This is from the rear or the flank.
You're gonna hear this guy talk about flanks all the time.
He's going to talk about firing movies,
give her talking of cover move as Lafe and I called it in our book cover and
move.
And this is again,
this is teamwork,
teamwork,
constantly working with your team and your other teams that are with you to make
sure that if I'm putting down cover fire,
you're moving,
and when you're putting down cover fire,
I'm moving.
You've got to work together to make that happen.
And every business in the world has multiple little units in it that have to
cover and move.
Talking about bravery and courage.
If we take the generally accepted definition of bravery as a quality,
which knows not fear.
I have never seen a brave man.
All men are frightened.
The more intelligent they are,
the more frightened they are.
The courageous man is the man who forces himself in spite of his fear to carry
on.
Yeah.
And where does that come from?
It comes from discipline,
pride,
self respect,
self confidence and the love of glory or attributes which will make a man
courageous even when he is afraid.
There's not too many people.
I mean you would,
Hackworth would never talk about the love of glory and just not,
not his deal.
Not as deal.
The w when you,
what you mentioned about bravery,
just how you were talking with Sam Harris about it,
where braveries only present if you are scared of something.
Because if you're not scared of it,
you're not being brave to overcome anything or to go,
you know,
to do any kind of activity that's um,
they,
that you're scared of.
So the very,
although I don't know if I necessarily agree with that because there's guys that
are,
you know,
he's says he's never seen anyone that's not not afraid.
I seen some pretty cool,
I mean it's almost the word to use.
It's like crazy guys that are just so brave in do you look at them and they,
they you go,
this guy is going to sky.
I had guys with me,
you know,
in my task unit and
some of those guys were so brave that I didn't think they were going to make it
home.
And it is it,
cause they were like,
um,
it's like they weren't scared to die at all.
Like it didn't,
yeah.
And,
and you see the,
almost a lack of self preservation,
you know,
not,
not stupid,
not suicidal,
but like,
oh this guy doesn't think he can be killed.
You know,
we were talking about that on the last podcast on,
and I forget the name of the major that was on the beach landing at Toro,
I think.
And he's up and he's like,
hey look,
they can't hit me.
Come on.
I've seen guys do that.
Yeah.
So
as far as actual bravery goes though,
so would you consider that,
um,
like let's say k two guys are going to go,
go do some,
let's say an MMA fight,
right.
And one guys were just really scared of competing in front of people.
It's his first fight or something like that.
Then you have this other guy who,
who's not,
who just feels different,
same exact situation,
but he's like fired up.
He's not scared at all and they both go into it.
Do,
did they both exercise the same bravery?
Yeah.
I don't know.
You know,
and I don't know if it matters.
Yeah.
For one thing,
I can tell you the guy that's acting like he's not scared,
it's probably the one that's more scared.
Yeah.
With MMA fights and it's,
and I actually see that combat two guys that are overly like bravado are
probably more scared.
And,
and again,
there's nothing wrong with that.
I'm not holding it against him.
But,
um,
you know,
I've seen guys sitting in briefs to go out operations
that you can tell are,
are,
are petrified.
Usually it's a guy that's
not used to it.
Maybe,
maybe someone that's visiting and an area of operations and shows up and it's,
oh,
we're going to take you out on a,
on an operation.
And you get to see them.
They're,
they're scared because they're not used to it.
All the guys from my task unit,
you know,
they might be scared,
but they're confident.
They know what they're doing.
They're,
they've,
they've put that fear aside over and over again.
So it's not that big of a deal,
but you see a guy dealing with that fear for the first time and especially
stands out because you've got a bunch of confident guys that,
that know,
that understand,
that,
understand the risks so you can see their faces.
Then you see like that guy that's come in from another area and is going to go
out and operation and,
and they're,
they're tapping their toes during the brief and they're looking around and they
got to overcome that fear.
And if they stay there for a few weeks,
they'll,
they'll get used to it too.
Yeah.
So it could kind of be looked at as,
um,
just,
just the act itself,
whatever act,
if it's understood as being,
yeah.
Yes.
Sam Harris,
his point was that it doesn't matter if there's a machine gun nest and you're
horrified to go charge it and I'm not,
and we both go charge it.
It,
you just had to pretend that,
that you weren't scared.
It doesn't matter.
You were still being brave and,
and I didn't have to pretend,
but I'm being brave.
So it doesn't matter whether you're pretending or not,
you're brave if you go and
well,
maybe just to overcome or do something that's understood generally as being
scary,
just as not security.
Yes.
Gary,
you,
you're still being just as brave.
You are.
But yeah,
I pay.
Yeah.
And I guess in a real black and white terms,
it's like if you're not scared of this activity you're doing and you do it and
you're not scared of it,
then you're not being brave.
And that's just in generally speaking like,
well,
skydivers skydivers with 5,000 jumps that are not right.
They're not scared anymore.
Yeah.
I mean,
I know even when I had done like,
you know,
50 jumps,
you're not really scared anymore.
Right.
You're just doing it.
And guys that have thousands jump,
they're not scared at all.
And that's what they do.
Right.
So they're not being brave.
They're just doing their job.
They're just doing their thing.
Yeah.
So what if some guy's jumping out for the first time and he's scared and he
overcomes that fear and jumps out?
He is being brave.
Yeah.
Right.
So yeah,
that's kind of the point.
Yeah.
So if I go outside and check the mail,
I'm not being brave.
No,
you're not being brave.
But what if there's like a tiger or something out there and I really need that
nail.
That's pretty brave,
right?
Tiger's going after tigers.
Yeah.
You're right.
Uh,
section here,
small unit tactics.
And you want us question whether I wanted to put this in there,
but I know that I'm getting a lot of feedback from guys that are in the
military,
guys that are in squat,
and this is something that I used to talk about and I know it's true.
Squads should sell them be split,
so you want to keep your force it together as much as possible.
However,
if it is necessary to split a squad,
be sure that the unit separated as at least capable of mutual support.
So is something I used to hammer the seals about.
If you get too far away from your other unit where you can't support them
anymore,
that's problematic.
Now that now that other units alone and that means that each unit that separate
should have the ability to support it means it has to have some firepower and
some strength.
This means that the unit separated from the squad should have not fewer than
three men.
The squad possesses in itself weapons necessary for a base and fire and
maneuvering element.
This should be an,
this should be,
it's in variable method of attack,
but the squad leaders should not spend so much time thinking which way he is
going to envelop that he suffers casualties,
which would have been avoided had he attacked at once.
So don't hesitate.
Don't sit around when it's time to get it on.
Get it on
Patton's a all about the taking action.
Another small unit tactic does a short one always captured the highest terrain
feature in your vicinity at once and stay on it.
And that is something that we executed all the time in Ramadi.
Get in the high ground getting those buildings.
Find the three story building amongst the two story buildings.
Find a two story building amongst the one story building.
Always looking for that high ground in the,
in the rural areas,
any kind of knoll and he kind of bump anything they give you.
The high ground is what you're looking for.
And as I said last time from an ethical and from a moral standpoint,
I ground take the high ground or the high ground it'll take you
got to watch out for that.
Don't delay the best is the enemy of the good.
And these are,
I mean that's just a common saying now the best is the enemy of the good.
By this I mean that a good plan violently executed now is better than a perfect
plan.
Next week.
War is a very simple thing and the determining characteristics are self
confidence,
speed and audacity.
None of these things can ever be perfect,
but they can be good.
He's talking about now general officer's meeting the senior leaders and these
apply to everything and not just senior leaders.
There are more tired division commanders than there are tired divisions.
Tired officers are always pessimists.
Remember this,
when evaluating reports,
generals must never show doubt,
discouragement or fatigue.
General should always adhere to one type of dress so that soldiers will
recognize them.
They must always be very neat and most importantly,
from my perspective,
I like what he says in cold weather.
General officers must be careful not to appear to dress more warmly than the
men.
Well,
you don't want to do that.
You don't want to be in the comfort zone when the boys are suffering.
You look like you're debating.
No,
no,
no.
I'm not giving it.
I was thinking about it.
Probably get shutdown,
but question,
send the question.
So
let's say you're a boss,
right?
You have this office and this office like decked out.
Meanwhile,
everyone on your team may have normal offices.
Is that an example of what he's,
no.
Generally,
because you actually do have more work to do.
You have,
you have to have meetings in your office.
And,
and,
and it's interesting too because,
uh,
I,
I didn't highlight it and in this for this series,
but they were saying that General Patton wasn't a four star general.
He was at 28 star general because when he would put his full uniform on,
he had four stars on his color,
on each color,
four star on each shoulder,
four stars in the helmet,
and four stars on each one of the handles of his pit of it's Pearl handled
pistol grip,
40 fives.
So the guy was like a little bit of,
I mean that's a,
that's a showman.
That's a,
that's a,
that's a diva,
right?
Yeah.
So he didn't know,
he knew that there a certain amount of showmanship to being in a leadership
position in that sort of what he's talking about by being recognizable.
I mean he's a very recognizable,
he had stars all over his cars and everything.
Yeah.
So it's more like the comfort of,
of battle.
So yeah.
But she could,
you could,
as a CEO,
you could absolutely take that to the wrong level where you're,
you know,
just living in total luxury and all your people are out and you cramped into
cubicles that,
you know,
your,
your folks would definitely look at you in a negative way.
Yeah.
But to,
but to have what's needed for the job,
you know,
of when I was to you commander,
I had an office that was mine,
you know,
and I had space in there to work.
Right.
But I wasn't,
you know,
shipping in stakes for me to have every night while the men were eating.
Right,
right.
[inaudible] yeah.
So just gotta be careful,
keep yourself in check a little bit.
What about when you travel,
you go FirstClass meanwhile,
you send your team and coach that.
I,
once again,
sometimes the boss is traveling first class,
cause when he lands he's got a present and he's gotta,
he's gotta be a little bit better rested sometimes.
The boss man has just sick of being cramped in a little tiny seats.
Mm hmm.
Well,
yeah,
you do.
Got It.
You got to keep that in check.
And I'll tell you when I was,
when I,
when I worked for the admiral of all the seals,
we didn't fly first class,
we were in the cheap seats who they are very careful about that.
They don't want to think that,
oh the the military elite is flying around first class.
No,
we were in the cheap seats sitting in the back of Delta,
you know,
eating peanuts.
Yeah.
There's so many justifiable reasons
in business.
Like you would go along with that
too,
but you just got to use your judgment.
You got to use your judgment and make sure that,
you know,
everyone's wearing,
a 10 year old field jacket when it gets cold and you're wearing a brand new down
and Gore Tex jacket,
you're people are going to not respect you.
You know,
you can't just deck yourself out when the boys or the troopers are
suffering.
Yeah.
And,
and how he mentioned where or how you mentioned what he's talking about where it
can be categorized as being recognizable,
you know,
so there's a lot of things,
even stuff outside of just uniform that a CEO,
how he presents himself.
Yeah.
That'll keep him recognizable.
Go for all these reasons.
But I'm sure,
I'm sure most of the time no one's perfect where they're gonna,
they're gonna start doing it discussed.
There's good business leaders now that,
that follow this type of lead.
I mean,
look at some of these new younger business leaders are not getting decked out.
I saw a picture of the guy that runs Facebook.
I saw a picture of his closet the other day.
He's got like a bunch of gray tee shirts in there.
Right.
You know,
and um,
from what I hear it like been to the office or nothing,
he,
his,
he doesn't have an office.
He,
there's this open space,
everyone's coding and stuff like that.
And he's just cruising in,
in there as well,
you know?
So yeah,
there's,
yeah.
I guess this all kinds of,
Yeah.
I guess it would depend on the business as well.
However,
this part is on debatable,
a general officer who will invariably assume the responsibility for failure,
whether he deserves it or not and invariably gives credit for success to others
whether they deserve it or not,
we'll achieve outstanding success.
It's a little something that we call extreme ownership.
You know,
that's the name of our book.
Someone that's taking ownership and there's Georgia has patents.
Sorry for Jack in your ideas.
George Askpat.
Yes.
I think that's crazy how that was like such a prominent idea back then because
like growing up and I dunno,
I just,
we never heard about that.
I know and when Lafe and I presented this book to people,
they don't say,
oh,
this is a very common theme that I've heard my whole life.
No,
they go,
this is outstanding and we're saying the exact same thing that general George
patents saying,
right.
Air,
which is a obviously extremely important,
issuing orders.
The best way to issue orders is by word of mouth from one general to the next.
Failing this telephone conversations,
which should be recorded at each end.
However,
in order to have a calm Fermentory memorandum of all oral orders,
given a short written order,
should always be made out.
Not necessarily at the time of issuing the order,
but it should reach the junior prior to carrying out the order so that if he has
forgotten anything,
he will be reminded of it and further in order that he may be aware that his
senior has taken definite responsibility for the operation ordered orally.
This is something that I used to do this all the time.
If I had a conversation with my boss,
I still to this day,
if I have a conversation with someone and we talk about something,
I'm following it up a little email because also oral conversations,
people hear what they want to hear and they might hear two different things.
You know,
if I tell you,
hey,
we're going to report record this podcast,
Hey,
can we record this podcast on Saturday?
You're like,
Oh yeah,
definitely.
Does that mean we are?
Does that mean in your mind you think we are,
but I didn't come back.
You know,
so I just follow stuff up and I used to do that in the seal teams to,
you know,
we'd get an order,
I'd get it,
I'd have a conversation with someone that was either above me or below me or
whatever.
I'd followed up with an email of what I thought the conversation meant and say,
hey,
just to confirm what we talked about,
here's the three bullet points.
I'm going to do this,
you're going to do that,
we're going to do this and boom,
it's done.
And we have a document of it and it exists.
And that we were confirmed how you bring up that example where if you say,
hey,
can we record a podcast on Saturday?
Technically you just,
that's a yes or no question.
Like,
yes we can.
We are,
we have that ability.
That's the night you didn't schedule anything you said.
So I could have taken it either way.
It can be like,
yeah,
we can,
and I show up here at eight and you're like,
oh yeah,
I didn't know we were actually going to do it.
You just said,
you know,
um,
when I first started getting,
uh,
more,
more higher end clients,
it was immediately noticeable that that was a common thing.
They'd always follow up with an email right after and it helps so much,
man.
It does.
You got to do it.
It is my,
Oh,
this,
I love this.
It is my opinion that army orders should not exceed a page and a half of
typewritten text.
And it was my practice not to issue orders longer than this.
Usually they can be done on a one page in the back of the page is used for a
sketch map.
W my favorite part about this is if you get someone that can't give you the
orders in like a page,
yeah.
Then that means there are orders are too complicated.
If that means they need to simplify their plan
and he's going to say this a few times,
commanders must remember that the issuance of an order or the devising of a plan
is only about 5% of the responsibility of command.
The other 95% is to ensure by personal observation or through interposing of
staff officers that the orders carried out.
Orders must be issued early enough to permit time to disseminate them.
So he's saying like,
Hey,
it's only 5% of your job to come up with a plan and disseminate the plan.
The other 95% of your job is to make sure it happens.
Take ownership of the plan and get it implemented,
and this is the most important part of this section.
Never tell people how to do things,
tell them what,
and they tell him what to do and they will you with their ingenuity.
So you want to give them sort of the broad,
hey,
this is what I want you to get done and let them figure out how to do it.
You're not going to be able to tell everybody on your team app what the do and
you want to do it and all that.
You got to let them run.
Yeah,
you got to use a little decentralized command is we like to say,
yeah.
In the creative world.
That's a really,
really significant thing to just say what you want and then let that person do
it.
Because if you have some creative vision,
let's do a little critique of Jocko.
How do I do with that?
Because you're,
you sort of the creative end here and how am I good as well?
I do.
I say,
you know what?
Echo,
here's what I think,
and then I just back away and let you run with your game.
Yeah,
and that's the,
yeah,
that's,
I don't manage.
No,
I don't micromanage,
especially in the creative field.
Well,
I don't know,
but I'm sure it's,
it's equally as applicable everywhere.
Yeah.
I realize that.
I can't,
when he was,
you got an expert,
you know,
it's the same thing.
There was an,
the teams,
it's same thing in the,
in the business world,
if you're the,
if you're the big boss,
man,
you shouldn't,
you're not going to know how to do all the technical things at the folks on the
front line.
You're not going to have the creativity because you're going to have the
capability because you got other things you should be worried about.
So get on those other things and let your people run.
Yeah.
Let him run.
And this,
uh,
it is sad to remember that when anyone is fairly mastered,
the art of command,
the necessity for that aren't usually expires either through the termination of
the war or through the advanced age of the commander.
And this is just a,
this is just a damn shame and it's the way it is.
And it's just,
it's this way in the military.
You're the,
would you start feeling like you've really gotten good at that job,
you're onto your next job.
And uh,
that doesn't feel good.
It's a bummer.
Um,
and there was a little
example when I talked about him being ultra aggressive,
and this is from a section,
this is from a section which I didn't take.
I don't think I took much out of it.
All this one's called,
or the section was called during my pain.
He talks about these important decisions that he made,
but they're there.
They take,
they're a little bit complex,
some of them,
but this one was fairly concise.
About the 5th of September,
it became apparent that we would run out of gasoline.
He's talking about for his tanks,
we would run out of gasoline.
I directed the two core to continue the advance until the tank's ran out of gas
and then to go on on foot.
This was actually done and the bridge head across the muscle river was secured.
As a result,
there was considerable resistance on the part of the corps commanders to do what
appeared to them an unnecessarily dangerous operation.
It's success again,
proved that it was not dangerous,
so that's,
that's pretty aggressive.
Hey,
you drive until the tank's running a gas in it takes to run a gas,
get out of the takes and walk.
Yeah,
that's a pretty legit,
we used to say like,
hey,
in the seal teams,
we're going to take the boats when the boats run out of of gas.
We'll tell the boats if the toe and boats run out of gas,
we'll get out and swim.
We'll keep going until we get it done.
Okay.
Letter of instruction number two.
So these are what,
these are what this guy and I love,
this is what this guy was writing as instructions to be handed out to all of his
men.
I mean,
and this is documented so you wonder what patent thinks about.
You don't have to wonder.
It's right here.
So here's this is letter of instruction.
Number two,
disciplined.
There is only one sort of discipline,
perfect disciplined men cannot have good battle discipline and pour
administrative discipline.
Discipline is based on pride in the profession of arms,
on meticulous attention to detail and on mutual respect and confidence.
Discipline must be a habit so ingrained that it is stronger than the excitement
of battle or the fear of death.
And this is why it's every day in every decision that you make and keeping that
discipline.
And I actually have been hearing,
you know,
I hear that this,
this,
that you will power deteriorates.
And I actually don't believe that.
I think the more they say,
oh,
you'll eat throughout the day,
you will power.
If you test it too many times it gets weaker and weaker.
And I actually don't believe that.
I actually believe it gets stronger.
Mind gets stronger when I'm,
yeah.
The more I hold the line,
the stronger the whole this,
the better the grip is clearly day by day,
day by day,
and normally like it's all together.
It's all grouped together.
When you wake up early and you get your workout in it,
you just stay on track.
You're like,
you know what?
I'm not going to eat that food that I don't need right now.
I'm not,
yeah.
You know,
it's so much easier.
But the day when you're like,
oh,
I didn't worry,
I woke up late and I didn't get my workout done.
And you know what,
there's a donut,
you know,
and it'd be breakdown.
So you want to,
you want to use the discipline.
Discipline enforces discipline.
Yeah.
Discipline more discipline makes more discipline.
It kind of seems like that.
It would be just like any other exercise,
writing your,
exercising your discipline.
So in May,
I don't know,
but maybe this is what that means when they say AP,
your willpower wears down,
let's say
trying to stick to this diet.
Right.
And you're going to be like,
Hey,
I'm not going to let myself get too hungry because when I let myself get too
hungry,
I know that doughnuts seem way more viable.
Doughnuts are not viable,
but you know,
as far as the pay it pay off,
uh,
you know,
Detrick it,
um,
you know,
it's like basically,
so if I test my willpower,
I'm just saying throughout the span of a day or you know,
however many hours when you start to get hungry,
so
they're saying,
okay,
so let's say you take your hunger to a certain point,
then you say,
you know what?
I'm going to stick the stick.
Stay strong.
Usually I eat way before this,
but I'm,
and I'm real hungry and really want those doughnuts,
but you know what?
I'm going to stick with it.
Right?
And you have that one,
that one experience of taking your hunger to a certain point and still sticking
to it.
You do that,
you let your hunger go on for even more.
That's your willpower wearing down,
wearing down,
but,
but say you stuck to it,
boom,
and you stuck to it that day.
Then the next day you have experienced going that far and your hunger and you
will be stronger and know how to deal with it.
I actually,
I actually disagree with you.
I think that when you stay strong you get stronger.
And when you break like how often does this happen?
All just have one bite of that donut for me every single time a then you have
that one bite of what happens.
Yeah,
yeah.
Gosh,
think a that one bite 10 bites.
So that's what I'm saying.
Stay strong.
Holds your discipline in place.
Okay.
Yeah.
So to compete,
compare that to like a workout.
Right?
So let's say I,
I do a hard set of,
I dunno pushups,
then I do another heart set of pushups.
I'm going to be less strong than that second set and I do another set,
I keep testing it,
but the next day or the next week I'm going to have benefits from that workout.
Yeah.
So it does reinforce,
um,
so the workout,
the fatigue is that temporary fatiguing.
You recover from it and then you're
stronger than way through that.
I think a better example is like when you say no to the one bite you or it's
easier to say no to the whole donut.
Yeah.
When you say yes to the one bite,
it's easier to say yes to the whole no.
That's so say no to dope.
Yeah.
Keep your discipline in tact.
Discipline back to the book.
Discipline can only be obtained when officers are so imbued with this sense of
they're awful obligation to their men into their country,
that they cannot tolerate negligence officers who fail to correct errors or to
praise excellent our value listen piece and dangerous misfits in war.
So he's giving equal equal importance to correcting errors and praising
excellence can see how important that is.
And that's something that I've never been very good at.
I was never a big praiser of excellence.
And in reading this,
I look back and say,
I should've done that more.
Yeah.
Officers must assert themselves by example and by voice they must be preeminent
in courage,
deportment,
and dress.
Okay.
One of the primary purposes of discipline is to produce alertness.
A man who is so lethargic that he fails to salute,
will fail,
we'll fall an easy victim to the enemy.
So the discipline just keeps you on track.
Combat experience has proven that ceremonies such as formal guard mounts,
formal retreat formations and regular and supervise Reveley formations are a
great help and in some cases essential to prepare men and officers for battle to
give them that perfect discipline,
that smartness of appearance,
that alertness without which battles cannot be one.
And this is something,
you know,
the seal teams for sure are
okay,
very on disciplined when it comes to uniforms,
when it comes to march,
I mean we don't March,
I mean we,
we barely can get into whenever,
whenever a bunch of seals have to do something militaristic.
It's usually a pretty,
we have to dumb it down and make it as easy as possible.
And because we just don't do it enough,
you know,
and,
and that's just,
I'm just,
I'm kind of stating that because we spend all of our time,
you know,
when we're,
when we're practicing for war,
we're not doing anything ceremonial.
We practice for war.
So this is kind of a funny little dichotomy there is that seals generally are
not ready for military inspection,
but they're ready for combat.
So there's a little little hypocrisies in a little heartbroken,
a little hypocritical item about that
combat principles.
Number one,
there is no approved solution to any tactical situation.
Little theme of creativity coming back again.
Yeah,
there's no approved solution.
You got to figure it out.
There is only one tactical principle which is not subject to change.
It is to use the means at hand to inflict the maximum amount of wounds,
death and destruction on the enemy,
the enemy in the minimum amount of time.
That's a pretty simple and straightforward principle and according to General
Patton,
it does not change.
Battles are won by frightening the enemy.
Fear is induced by inflicting death and wounds on him.
Death and wounds are produced by fire.
Fire from the rear is more deadly and three times more effective than that from
the front.
But to get fire behind the enemy,
you must hold him by frontal fire and move rapidly around his flank.
Frontal attacks against prepared positions should be avoided if possible.
I told you he was going to talk about flanks.
He's talking about flanks.
Catch the enemy by the nose with fire and kick them in the pants with fire in
place through movement.
That's flanks.
You can never get too strong.
Get every man and gun you can secure provider does not unduly delay your attack.
I used to say we,
we've tried to figure out how many guys would bring on a mission and I'd get
some kind of,
you know,
restriction like,
Hey,
we only want you to bring this many guys.
And I'd say,
well this isn't soccer where we're only allowed to bring 11 per side.
Well why would I not bring 38 if I can bring 38 why would I stop myself at 28
seven you don't bring as many people as you can and let's go,
let's rock and roll.
The larger force and the more violence you use in the attack,
whether it be men tanks or ammunition,
the smaller will be your proportional losses.
Violence of action is what we used to call that in the seal teams.
Violence of action never yield ground.
It is cheaper to hold what you have than to retake what you have lost.
Never permit a unit to dig in until the final objective is reached.
Then dig wire and mine.
So you can't rest until you get to good spot.
I I,
this is a little statement I used a lot in Jujitsu coaching cause cause people,
they,
they get in a position and they rest before it's time to rest.
You know,
you gotta you gotta get the guard back.
You've got it.
If someone,
if someone passed your guard,
you don't,
you'll settle there on your back and let them settle in and start to smash you.
As soon as someone passes your guard,
your recovery,
your work,
you don't,
you don't settle down until you're back to a good position.
You can never do that.
I noticed that and I actually brought it up to remember less than just last week
or whatever when we rolled.
And I was like,
there's something that I noticed about you that,
um,
and that was that in the scramble,
you won't just settle and hangout in my guard.
You don't even accept the guard.
And he talks about it a long time ago before,
but it was real for whatever reason,
just really prevalent that day.
That yeah.
In the scramble,
scramble goes on for let's say a longer time.
Let's say the scramble goes on for six seconds.
Pretty Long.
Scrambles it.
It seems like you still wouldn't even stop the scramble until you're beyond the
guardian,
the girl.
Yeah.
You won't just hang out with me of,
Hey,
I thought I'd see it right in that garden,
get my restaurant.
But um,
and it's surprisingly painfully affective.
Yeah.
Do that.
I was talking to Dean about that yesterday.
If Dean is in a mindset where he's accepting a guard pass or he's accepting,
it becomes a much,
much,
much easier game when he decides he's not going to let you settle until he gets
to the advent advantageous position.
It's a nightmare because he won't stop moving and he's a good scrambler.
The F.
You know what's interesting about these,
I have a note in here that you know,
he said never yield ground,
never permit a units.
Dig In.
He says never.
And that's something that I own Sec,
right?
Because it takes away the fact that of what he said earlier about there's no
written rule.
There's no approved method.
You shouldn't use that word.
Never.
Because sometimes you should yield ground and sometimes you should
dig in even when the final objective is.
So I know he's just being extreme,
but it is.
I did make a note of that to point out general training back to the book,
more emphasis will be placed on the hardening of men and officers.
All soldiers and officers should be able to run a mile with combat pack and 10
minutes and March,
eight miles and two hours.
Okay.
The hardening of men and officers,
he goes on to say sharpen axes,
pick axes and shovels now and keep them sharp.
Okay?
That's just an attitude,
right?
Look,
the pick ax that you're gonna use to dig in,
make it sharp because you got to hack somebody's brain out.
Keep it sharp.
Yeah.
Battles are fought by platoons and squads.
Place emphasis on small unit combat instruction.
So that is conducted in the same precision as close order drill.
A good solution applied with vigor now is better than a perfect solution.
10 minutes later.
Common theme.
Okay.
Needless requirements.
He's actually got a section here called needless requirements.
There is a tendency,
and I used to see this in the military and I see it in businesses now,
this is the needless requirements.
There's a tendency for the chain of command to overload junior officers by
excessive requirements in a way of training and reports.
You will alleviate this burden by eliminating nonessential demands.
You go to any business and they've got reports that people are generating and
meetings that they're attending and conference calls.
That's what this is about.
Those are needless requirements.
Get rid of them.
Yeah man.
Especially those meetings like
I think people just like meetings cause it,
it,
um,
it helps them think or feel like they're doing something,
doing something,
you know?
Which do you make meetings 20 minutes long,
Brad?
Just call them on the phone.
Yeah.
Or You just call him on the phone.
But meetings would make them make your meetings 20 minutes long if you have to
schedule them,
show up on the meeting,
ready to,
don't need,
don't need to learn anything.
Let us know what we're going to talk about.
Let's talk about the decision because that's what everyone needs to get on the
phone for.
It's for the decision.
Yeah,
you should.
You can get informed by reading a quick bulleted list.
So I go over those bullets with me when I already did that.
Yeah.
Unless they have questions or something like that,
like I got a question.
That's what I'm saying.
That's the discussion piece.
Yeah.
And then in the meeting,
a lot of the time,
let's say there's a meeting of 10 guys and let's say three,
four guys or are discussing stuff and maybe they're trying to solve this problem
that they specifically have.
And then the other few guys,
they feel compelled to want to be contributing to the meeting.
So they say just more of the stuff that's so unnecessary.
Just so they can have to say in the meeting
Sidebar,
take it somewhere else.
You've angered echo people,
tobacco,
the meetings,
keeping them 20 minutes.
There's a whole,
there's a whole lot of people in America,
in business world that are listening to that needless requirements and they're
thinking about the need,
this requirements they fulfill on a daily basis and it makes them angry.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a source of frustration.
I talked to folks about it all the time,
like they feel like they don't have time to do their job and we felt like that
in the military.
Like,
are you serious?
We have to do,
you know,
fill out this document,
attend another call with the so-and-so commander.
Just tell me,
you know,
give me the highlights and let me do my work.
I got a job to do here.
People,
infantry,
infantry must move in order to close with the infantry must move in order to
close with the enemy.
It must shoot in order to move again.
There's covering move when physical targets are not visible.
The fire of all infantry weapons must search the area occupied by the enemy,
use marching fire.
It reduces the accuracy of his fire and increases our confidence.
Shoot Short ricochets make nasty or sounds and wounds.
That's something that they used to have us do all the time in the seal teams so
you don't eat.
You make sure you're shooting low if you're going to make a mistake,
aim low.
So the to the rounds hit in front of where the enemy is and they ricochet up and
they hit him with all kinds of frag and rocks and you have a chance of still
hitting.
If you shoot over their head and it misses him,
it's called Gotcha.
Interesting to halt under fire is folly to halt under fire and not fire back his
suicide.
And this is what we just talked about in Jujitsu to halt under fire.
That's what you're doing when you win,
when you let me keep scrambling,
when you stop scrambling,
that's what I'm going to get a little thing.
You're halting under fire and guess what it says here that that is suicide.
Move forward.
Out of fire officers must set the example.
Few men are killed by the bay and net.
Many are scared by it ban that should be fixed.
When the firefight starts,
bayonets must be sharpened by the individual soldier.
The German hates the band net and is inferior to our men with it are men should
know this little psychological warfare here and you got to sharpen your own band
that you're better at it than the enemy.
Put that thing on the end of your gun when the firefight starts and get ready to
get some.
Yeah,
that's,
that's general pattern right there.
Keeping it real.
I wanted to work for General Patton.
Care of men.
Officers are responsible not only for the conduct of their men in battle,
but also for their health and contentment when not fighting and officer,
and this is where he's going back to the CEO and how they act and officer must
be the last man to take shelter from fire and the first to move forward.
Similarly,
he must be the last man to look after his own comfort at the close of a march.
He must see that his men are cared for.
The officer must consider constantly inner interest himself in the rations of
the men.
He should know his men so well that any sign of sickness or nervous strain will
be apparent to him and he can take such action as may be necessary.
Same thing we were,
we were talking about
and we're about to,
uh,
wrap this up here with a couple more and I kind of saved the best for last to be
quite honest with you.
Such as this right here,
command leadership.
And this is a,
this is actually another letter of instructions to the,
again,
this is just what you want to know.
How general patent fought here.
It is his own words on what he wanted his men to know as they prepared for
combat leadership.
Full duty.
Each in his appropriate sphere will lead in person.
Any commander who fails to obtain his objective and who is not dead or severely
wounded has not done his full duty.
Doesn't need to be much clearer than that.
Yeah,
there's your,
there's your standard.
If you're not dead or severely wounded and you haven't achieved your objective
objective,
you haven't done your full duty visits to the front.
The commanding general,
his chief of staff should visit the front daily.
The function of these is to observe,
not to meddle.
In addition to their own specialty,
they must observe and report anything of military importance.
Remember that praise is more valuable than blame.
Yeah,
so if you're going to go to the front line troops,
don't go up there and blame them.
Praising them.
Remember too that your primary mission as a leader is to see with your own eyes
and be seen by your troops while engaged in personal recognizance
execution,
in carrying out a mission.
The propagation of the order represents not over 10% of your responsibility.
The remaining 90% consists in assuring by means of personal supervision on the
ground by yourself and your staff proper and vigorous execution.
And that's when we already talked about,
yeah,
you put together the plan.
Yeah.
You disseminated the plan.
That's great.
Your job is to make it happen and ensure that it happens.
Take ownership of it and execute it.
Okay.
Plans.
Plans must be simple and flexible.
Actually.
They are only a form of data plain from which you build as necessity directs or
opportunity offers.
So he's saying that plan is just a,
just something to build off of as,
as necessity directs or opportunity offers.
I got asked this the other day at a,
at a,
at an event,
you know,
when do you know what it's time to change the plan when I,
when necessity directs or opportunity offers,
that's when you make the change.
Hmm.
Plans should be made by the people who are going to execute them.
Yeah.
Formal orders.
Formal orders will be proceeded by letters of instruction and by personal
conferences.
In this way,
the whole purpose of the operation will be made clear together with the mission
to be accomplished by each major unit.
So he's saying that though the,
the whole purpose of the operation will be made clear
so that if during combat,
during combat communication breaks down,
each commander can and must so act as to obtain the general objective.
Okay.
There you go.
So if you understand what the overall broad mission is,
when we go out to attack in,
all of a sudden you're separated from us or you don't,
can't communicate with us anymore or so something happens and you need to make
an adjustment,
your plan,
as long as you know what the broad mission is,
the whole purpose of the operation of which later ended up being called the
commander's intent.
That's what we called it and eh,
in the modern military w as long as you know what the commander's intent is,
what the intent of the operations,
then you can execute on your own.
You don't need any more direction from me.
Yeah,
go and make it happen.
Keep your own orders short.
Get them out in time.
Issue them personally by voice when you can
keep troops informed,
use every means before and after combat to tell the troops what they are doing,
what they are going to do and what they have done.
Reiterating discipline.
There is only one kind of discipline.
Perfect discipline.
If you do not enforce and maintain discipline,
you are potential murderers.
You must set the example condition.
Hi,
physical condition is a vital to victory.
We talked about that and we about that all the time.
Your physical conditioning,
high physical condition is vital to victory.
There are more tired core and division commanders than there are tired core and
divisions.
Fatigue makes cowards of us all men in condition do not tire.
So you gotta be in shape.
And here's the close,
and this is the last one,
and it's the shortest one and it's probably the most important one to remember
from general patent
courage.
Do not take counsel of your fears.
That's it.
That's what he had to say about courage to all of his troops as they embarked on
this intense combat day after day,
week after week.
You want to know what you do with your fear.
Do not take counsel of your fears,
No vote.
They don't get a vote and your fears don't get a vote.
So next time you feel that fear,
no matter what it is,
it's pretty easy.
You the you don't take counsel,
love it.
They get no vote.
That's general patent.
Great Book,
Great Leader,
lots to learn,
lots to pass on
war as I knew it.
Questions from the interweb.
Yeah.
First Question Jocko Willink is Bjj really practical for street defense where
there are no rules.
My understanding is that it doesn't fair well against knives and multiple
attackers compared to something like Krav Maga.
Muy Thai boxing.
So this is a
good question obviously and it's a question that we get a lot.
I get a lot.
Uh,
I actually did a video,
we did a video like this and Tim Ferriss port it out so you can look for that.
If you kind of want to hear another version of this,
maybe we could link to it on Jocko podcasts.
I think we can do that.
Yeah.
Excellent.
Um,
what,
okay,
so self where we're talking about true self defense here.
First and foremost,
most important thing,
and I actually didn't say this on the last video,
but I should say it now,
is situational awareness and putting yourself in good situations where bad
things are not going to happen to you and doing that to the best of your ability
and your being aware of your surroundings.
That's the very important first step in self,
second
guns.
Uh,
if you are a person that really needs to defend yourself and you live in a
horrible area and there's violent people around and you might be us small,
a very small person or you might be elderly or you might have some sort of a
physical limitation,
then how you're going to defend yourself is using guns using a gun.
So I mean that's just,
that's just the way it is
now.
Okay.
So that being said,
uh,
maybe you can't have a gun,
maybe you don't have a gun and you don't always want to have to pull a gun out.
Even though a gun is a great deterrent in most people if they see that you have
a gun or not going to want to fight you anymore.
But obviously you can't be just yanking the gun out at anything that happens and
you don't always have them with you.
For instance,
you know,
in certain places you're not allowed to have a gun.
Certain states,
you're not allowed to have a gun in the,
in the water.
If you're surfing,
you're not allowed to have a gun.
Uh,
so what do you do?
How does did you to stack up against these other martial arts?
I say that you should learn Jujitsu first should be the first martial art that
you try and learn to defend yourself.
And there's a reason for that.
There's a bunch of reasons for that.
Number one,
it's sort of a base reason,
but do you do to is probably the most complex to learn.
There's the,
it's the,
it's the most three dimensional martial art.
It's not linear,
it's very three dimensional.
There's a ton to learn.
It's infinite in what you can learn.
So you want to get into it early because it's going to take longer to learn it.
But that's,
that's actually a secondary reason.
The primary reason to learn Jujitsu first is because of the nature of self
defense situations.
So
we are born with our primary form of self defense and we learn it from a very
young age.
And our primary form of self defense will keep you safe from most of these
situations.
And that is running
and using your legs to run.
So,
and if you think of,
now think about this,
you're kind of chuckling because you don't understand the gravity of what I'm
saying cause it's very accurate.
So listen,
we're talking about self defense.
We're not talking about offense,
we're talking about defense.
How do you stay safe?
Yeah.
So if I square off with you,
okay.
And I want to fight and punch you
runaway,
I am not holding onto you,
right?
I had run away if there's me and three of my friends
run away,
if I have a knife and I'm going to try and stab you,
runaway.
So all these kind of attacks there,
a disconnected attack.
I'm not holding onto you.
So run away from me.
Get out of there.
Run into a public place.
Run to where there's other people that can help you run.
Where this changes
is when somebody grabs a hold of you.
When somebody grabs a hold of you,
you can no longer run away and you have to be able to make them on grab you let
go of you.
And how do you do that?
You do that by knowing how to grapple and grappling as Jujitsu.
So that is why the first thing you should learn is Jujitsu.
Because if someone's not grabbing a hold of you,
run away from them.
If someone's trying to square off and and go toe to toe with you,
If there's five guys that want to fight,
you run away from them.
If someone pulls out a knife on you run.
But here's the deal.
If that person knocks you down and gets on top of you,
you can't run anymore.
So what do you have to do?
You have to grapple them and you have to know Jujitsu to to get them up and off
of you and get away from them or submit them and put them to sleep or break
their arm.
That is why you should start with Jujitsu.
Pretty straightforward.
Agreed.
Once you know Jujitsu,
absolutely.
Learn Moitai,
learn wrestling,
learn boxing,
learned Krav Maga,
learn a screamer on it.
Learn everything you can about fighting.
Do It of course,
but set your base with the one that you're going to need if somebody grabs you.
And that's Jujitsu.
The other thing about Jujitsu is it's pretty easy to add in
some of these other more animalistic self defense situations.
So if somebody grabs you and pulls you to the ground and you want to get away
from there,
yeah you can.
You need to know your body positions,
but it's pretty easy to decide you're going to bite their ear off or big take a
big chunk
out of their face with your teeth or GM,
your fingers into their eyes.
It's,
it's not hard to augment that stuff.
Yeah.
So these are all things that you can do within Jujitsu that Jujitsu does not
hamper that ability to be savage in your attacks on people.
And that's interesting you bring up,
because
everyone's heard the guy where he'll be like,
hey,
what's that?
You get through whatever.
And then,
I dunno,
you just show him where you explain it and they'll be like,
oh,
wolf all just all,
I just gouge your eyes out right here.
Or I just,
um,
you know,
I don't know the strike your throat or something like this.
Right.
So take the eye gouging option.
You don't have to be trained to eye gouge.
So we both,
well I go to each other like if you're,
if we're going to go eye gouging.
Yeah.
I've had people try not to gouge me before.
It's not going to stop it and that it hasn't stopped.
That's a second point.
Um,
Sarah's brother,
we was off for like,
metamorris were talking and he,
he,
he'd basically did that.
He was asking questions.
He'd be like,
no,
I won't lie.
I don't have to learn Jujitsu.
I would just do this.
And he'd like,
he's like,
I know like pressure points that sub people.
And I was like,
yeah.
So I said,
okay,
Darth Vader.
Yeah,
exactly.
So I was like,
okay,
well what's the pressure point though?
So I was like,
okay,
do the pressure point on me.
I won't even like fight you back.
And he did the one like here by the neck.
And I was like,
not only does that not hurt right now,
I mean I can see it.
It hurts more than if you did it here.
But not only does that not really hurt that much right now,
if,
if we're in any kind of fight situation,
I don't even think I would even notice that they'll still,
he was like,
oh yeah,
yeah,
will live you get this one.
And he did one like behind me here and then where my ribs,
same exact thing.
It's yet,
it's more sensitive for sure.
But it's not going to start a fight,
man.
Yeah,
it's,
it simply does not work.
But the Jujitsu,
you know,
Jujitsu,
you can still do all those things if you want to do it,
but you don't even have to.
Yeah.
Cause we're going to put them to sleep.
And I would say even in my opinion,
more accurately do you do to help you?
Or it'll give you the ability to control the fight.
Oh,
for sure.
So you can look,
if you get to,
you're not going to learn how to throw like a sick left hook or nothing like
that.
You're not going to learn that.
But you'll control the fight where if you want to punch someone,
you'll be in the perfect position to punch him no matter how much punching
training you have.
You can have no punching training and you can just,
I dunno,
just throw your fist at them in whatever capacity.
It will be way more effective when you know Jujitsu and that goes through any
other one of these moves that people say they'll do if you do Jujitsu on them,
know you're the one going to control the fight.
With all those people who've come to me and I've gone through them all,
no factor of the pressure points,
the this,
the,
that doesn't work.
Sorry.
Sorry to tell you.
It might work like you know the risk ones if you sit there
and let them do it and be like,
okay,
yeah,
that hurts.
And also going against someone that's completely untrained.
You can't have some sort of success with some of this stuff.
Right.
Not against a determined attacker.
Kind of the point where it's like,
yeah,
I say,
it might work if you let them do it,
but that's the thing.
You don't let them do it.
So ultimately it learned the likelihood of that work can very,
very low.
Just in the spirit of fairness.
Fun.
Yeah.
It's creative.
It's a good workout.
It ups your confidence.
It gets,
you used to come combative situations where you're going 100% you get,
you used to having someone grind on you and try and smash you.
That's a big deal that I didn't even think about where just having someone in,
in girls especially or just people who aren't used to confrontation and then
when you get in a fight,
it inoculates you to the terror of having somebody all up winding up on you and
trying to smash you.
I want to say it was UFC
for which one was one with our Jimmerson with the one glove was that it was a
wall and that was one.
Okay,
so he got mounted and tapped in men.
That's a perfect example.
He didn't get punched,
you know,
he didn't tap from any kind of punch or submission old.
He got mounted and then in an interview later I saw,
he said,
man,
I was just feeling claustrophobic over there.
And if you watch it,
he wasn't mounted for very long.
No,
it was just,
man,
he just wasn't used to that.
And in hedging,
if that was a real life fight,
someone attacks you and they're like,
oh,
I'm good on you and you don't know,
then you can't tap man.
You're,
you're not gonna be able to handle that.
Right.
If you know Jujitsu,
you get mounted.
That's no factor.
Press to some people they know mountainscapes so good where they hope they get
mobbed until they can get on top.
You know?
And then so you compare those two sides of the spectrum do just to know that you
get to know the Jujitsu.
Next,
next question.
Can you expand on how to appropriately,
effectively and tactfully lead up the chain of command in a profession that's
considered to be very paramilitary?
My Line of work.
Sometimes it works against this limiting,
limiting ideas and ways of doing things and they're talking about the tradition
in their line of work.
Uh,
okay.
So what do you do?
You got to organization you're working in and you've,
how do you lead up the chain of command?
Well,
eat
even in a paramilitary organization of which you know,
infers that this is a very hierarchical structure and its chain of command
driven,
that how do you possibly get your boss to do what you want them to do?
Well,
it's actually fairly simple,
fairly simple.
Not Easy,
but simple.
It,
it is hard to do.
It does take a lot more though.
It does take a lot of tack.
It takes a lot of patients.
So number one,
you got to build trust.
You've got to build trust with your,
the people that are above you and the chain of command.
You got to build a relationship.
You got to be proactive.
You've got to stay ahead.
You know,
when I joined the military I one,
you know one day just told my dad,
hey by the way,
I joined the,
I enlisted in the navy,
I'll be,
I'll be gone in three weeks or whatever if my dad just looked at me and shook
his head and he says,
you're going to hate the military cause you hate authority.
You don't listen to anybody.
And I was kind of a young stupid kid and I'm like whatever.
I'm going in the seal teams,
it's a team.
We don't have to listen to anybody.
Of course I was completely wrong and you do listen to people and you do have a
chain of command.
But he was right in the fact that I didn't like to listen to people and I didn't
like authority.
So how did I get ahead of that?
It was pretty easy.
What I did to get ahead of that was I got ahead of it and that's what you need
to do here.
You have to start that,
start that attitude of where you're doing what needs to be done before you get
told to do it.
So you start to appear to have more knowledge and good foresight of what's going
to happen.
Now you got to be careful that you're not showing up the boss.
You can't be throwing in their face and already did that,
you know,
because I'm so much better than you.
That's not the goal here.
The goal is to build confidence,
not to build animosity.
You don't want to build animosity.
You want to build trust,
you want to build confidence.
You want to make that person start to realize how good you are.
Again,
be careful not to throw it in their face.
Now,
the tradition piece and,
and sometimes people do cling on to the traditions and they use the traditions
to shut down evolution.
And that's bad because what they're really doing is they're protecting their
world.
They're protecting their existence.
And so that's a,
that's a big wall.
That's a big hard wall to get through.
Now most people do have traditions and traditions.
What are traditions built on?
Do We build traditions?
Are Traditions of failure and we're proud of that or the traditions of losing or
Pat,
no,
no.
The traditions are proud traditions,
the traditions of winning their traditions,
of excellence.
And in some way traditions of excellence and traditions of winning and
traditions of domination have to be tied in some way
to evolving into adapting and to getting better.
Because that's how we win.
That's how we dominate.
So you have to find that hole in the tradition,
that part of the tradition that implies that what we do in our tradition is we
get better.
That's all it is.
You just got to find that thing that says we get better,
we win.
And you take that and you carry that,
that lead that little crack in the armor of tradition and you turn that into,
you know,
yeah,
we have a proud tradition because we're the best.
And if you're going to be the best is the best stagnate.
No,
the best evolves.
And again,
you gotta be careful.
You can't throw this in their face.
You got to say,
Hey,
you know what?
Our traditions that we're the best.
We make things happen and we get things done and we always do it better than
everyone else.
So you know what?
Here's one way we could do a better,
we did this.
You got to look for those little Araks in the tradition to bring forward change.
Now again,
the most important thing though is you got to continue to build that
relationship with your superiors.
You're constantly trying to build that,
and I've said this before,
and I'll say it again.
No matter who I ever worked for,
I had the same relationship with the crazy boss,
with a knucklehead boss,
with the loser,
with a great guy,
had the same relationship all the time,
and that was they trusted me,
didn't matter who I work for.
So you got to build that relationship of trust.
You've also got to be careful that as you're trying to be proactive and as
you're trying to get things done,
that you're not looking to do it for your own ego to get credit,
because that disturbs the people at the top.
It makes them say,
oh,
he's just trying to shine.
He just trying to look good.
Screw him,
throw his ideas out.
That's what you got to watch out for.
So that's your ego.
Don't make your ego fight their ego because they've got an ego too.
You want to let your ego go,
okay,
build that relationship.
Make the change slow.
It's going to be slow,
steady,
and it's going to take persistence in the long war.
Dope.
You got to have patients.
Tradition doesn't break down overnight.
Tradition takes time to morph.
So you gotta be ready for that long war and don't get frustrated.
You're a part of a winning team.
You're part of a team that has a proud tradition.
You just got to add to that tradition and that's gonna take time.
That's how you do it.
Next question.
Hi Guys.
How about on a podcast?
Do you talk about what is the essential equipment for a home gym?
Uh,
okay.
So for me,
first of all,
if you have nothing,
if you're building from zero,
the first thing you need is pull up bars,
a pull up bar and a dip bar somewhere.
Did you dips in somewhere to do pull ups in?
And that's what you need.
Now be careful if you're listening and you're like,
okay,
I'm going to go buy,
pull up bar.
In a dip bar.
Don't get the little flimsy looking things that costs $129.
Do you don't want that.
It's almost worthless.
It's better than nothing but is almost worthless.
You want to get a legit dip bar and a legit pull up.
Our dip bars are a little bit easier.
You can go,
you can go pretty cheesy on dip bars,
but pull up bars.
You can pull up bars,
you need something legit strong,
you can bolt it to your wall,
but you need a nice pull up bar with a,
with a inch and a half or a two inch metal pipe.
I still have a pull up bar that I bought from home depot.
Uh,
I bought it in 1998 I've had it ever since and it's bolted on to my squat rack,
but that's all it is.
A piece of,
you know,
two inch pipe and that's what you do pull ups on.
So when you say it,
make sure it's legit.
Why is that so you don't feel it doesn't break while you're using it basically.
Yeah.
And also it's got to have some weight to it.
So you can do kipping pull ups or you're not,
the thing's not shaking all over the place.
You get,
you see these,
I mean this is just going total cheese ball,
but things with like the foam handles that just rotate and fall off and they're
just,
it's just a nightmare.
You want to,
what you need is a pipe,
has what you need is a piece of pipe from home depot
and,
and then you need somewhere to do dips.
Now one thing that you can do that will cover both these as you can get rings,
you know,
gymnastics rings and you can have,
you can adjust the height of the rings and you can do dips and pull ups on
ranks.
And then you can do muscle ups as well.
So rings are Omel.
So like if there's one thing you could have,
if you could have one piece of equipment for working out,
it probably be smart to go with just wooden rings,
uh,
because that there are that flexible and you can do that much different stuff.
I mean you can do dips,
you can do muscle ups,
you can do pull ups,
you can do pushups,
can do all kinds of stuff.
You can do levers,
you can do front levers,
back levers,
there's all kinds of gymnastic movie you can do.
I mean,
you could basically work for the rest of your life on rings and be good to go.
So rings are a way of handling the whole pull up and dip bar situation.
But,
and that's why it's pretty much the number two thing for me is,
is
pull up bark dip bar slash,
rinks because those are all going to kind of get you those basic body movements
to build your strength.
Uh,
once you get past that,
now it's time for a squat rack.
It's got to have a squat rack.
And as soon as you have a squat rack,
now my school,
my squat rack has a pullup bar on it,
which I bolted on myself.
My squat rack is the same year when I bought my first house,
immediately had a garage gym.
It was 20,
I don't know,
27 years ago or something that built
a garage gym immediately bought a squat rack.
It's still have the same squat rack bolted,
a pull up bar onto it's still have that.
I modified it a little bit and made dip bar.
So I had a dip bar on it.
This is before you could buy gymnastic rings or I didn't know how to get ahold
of gymnastics rings back in those days.
And then the next thing get you need is you need,
um,
an Olympic lifting bar and,
and bumper plates.
And so you can do your squats,
your cleans,
your cleaning jerks,
your dead lifts,
and all your basic strength movements.
Okay.
Um,
after that,
for me,
I think kettle bells,
um,
you know,
so now you have,
you can do your swings,
you can do your farmer's walks,
you can do your snatches,
you can,
I mean,
there's a ton of exercises,
Turkish getups.
I mean there's a ton of exercises that you can do there that kettle bells now
add to the situation and you can do some really psychotic conditioning,
metabolic conditioning with the addition of kettle bells as well.
At this point,
if you only have one set of rings,
I have three sets of rings and I have one that's high for muscle ups.
I have one that's medium for depths and I have one that's low for for pushups
and I just have those all the time.
So then you don't have to adjust them cause I guess I'm too lazy to want to
adjustment rings all the time.
The next piece for me is
I like rowers.
The concept two rowers,
I have one,
I've had it for a long time.
They're brutal workout.
I think that you can just destroy yourself very easily and very quickly and I
think like uh,
like an Airdyne or an air assault type bike,
I don't have one of those.
I'm probably going to get one very soon,
but I think those are outstanding as well.
I didn't say jump rope earlier.
That's another good kind of cardio kind of metcon kind of get after it and then
maybe some medicine balls.
Um,
and after that,
I mean I think,
you know,
the question was essential equipment to me,
that's sort of my list.
And then from there it just becomes fun.
You know,
it becomes a,
what kind of other implements can I bring into the situation that are going to
eliminate boredom,
increase creativity,
increased dynamic and functional movement.
And I think these,
these are pretty good and this is all stuff that's pretty common nowadays.
There's a bunch of different places to get it and make it happen.
Yeah.
Especially,
especially when you kind of start with kind of one thing and you slowly just add
on.
Yeah.
And essential.
That's kind of a complex question in any way to,
to begin with.
And you did say for you,
right?
So it depends on what kind of gym you're doing.
Like what kind of results you want you.
So if you're,
everyone that's listening to this podcast wants to just peak physical
conditioning in a broad array of,
of environments and tasks.
I would assume that as well.
But it's not necessarily a fat.
So like I'm just saying if they have different goals but name are going to look
different.
Name a goal that won't be covered by this.
You can't do it and get their bench up.
Okay.
That's it.
That's one.
If you weren't,
if you want to get your bench up,
you need to bench.
Yeah.
I think your list is pretty elaborate cause so it's just my opinion because
you're going to break it down cause you're like a minimalist over here.
And when it comes to working out,
no,
let's hear.
Most well essential equipment,
right?
I would say the many depends.
So yeah.
Okay.
It does.
Yes.
It depends on what you,
what results you want.
So if you just want to be a bodybuilder with big muscles,
go to listen to different podcasts.
That's not the question.
The question and the people that are asking these questions are listening to his
podcasts.
They into physical fitness.
They want to be healthy,
they want to be Jujitsu players,
they want to be fighters.
They wouldn't be able to functionally move well.
They want to stay healthy.
They're not just getting their bodybuilder on.
Okay.
That's still is it assumption though?
But it's correct assumption for the sake of efficiency.
I'm going to go ahead and I'm gonna let you,
I'll tell you what,
make that assumption as well.
One minute to come down.
It's not about completing the list.
I was going to elaborate a little bit more,
but do no,
I think that,
and I actually,
I agree with you.
You're gonna have any elaboration then just one more thing.
You probably added a bench on there.
Yeah.
Is that what your dad on anything else?
Anything that would,
that would,
yeah,
that would facilitate the same thing a bench would facilitate.
Other than that,
it's pretty a pretty good list I think.
Yeah,
I think that's uh,
yeah,
that's a big time.
I think that's the deluxe lists though,
man.
I think you could cut a few of those losses.
Still get good eats.
It's a,
it's an escalation though.
If someone's listening right now and they're like,
you know what,
I'm going to go get in shape.
First thing you do is get a set of rings that you can do.
Pull ups and that's number why I got you.
Then you can get a squat rack,
then you with the squat racks going to come with a pull up bar and a dip bar
somehow.
So you're good there.
Then you,
then you got to get the bar and bumper plates right,
which you can escalate.
You can start with,
uh,
you can start with just a bar and you know,
to 25 pound bumper plates and then every month by another 45 pounds or a hundred
pounds or whatever and you're good after you see those gains you started
jacking.
The biggest thing about home gyms is if you work out at home,
especially this,
these kinds of workouts,
you get more of a testosterone boost.
If you work out at edit
public gym,
like at a 24 hour fitness or crossfit gym or something.
If you work out well,
it basically,
if you work out in front of people,
if there's other people around you,
you get a testosterone booster,
how still then you would,
it's,
it's this thing where,
I dunno,
it's weird,
it's,
there's some guy did an experiment long time ago where,
um,
I dunno how long ago,
but he did an experiment where he found out all these little things that you can
do in front of people that will boost your testosterone.
One was like drive a car,
like a certain kind of car and if you do it in front of people,
it boosts your testosterone.
So if you,
and not only do you get,
get that,
you get,
um,
cycle mental priming as well.
So when you walk in the gym,
like the crossfit gym,
all the smells,
the sounds and all that basically primes your mind and your physiology for a
workout.
So don't take it at home.
I mean,
I'm sure you could do that.
I don't think he would,
it would replace the actually being there.
Just that part of it.
I'm not saying home gyms are junk.
I'm not saying that at all cause when I walk in my home gym fee you are prying.
I feel Brian
and that's part of it as well.
So,
um,
the whole reason,
the whole reason I set up a home gym was so I don't have to make that drive to
the gym and you know Gil
but that kind of works against interesting that you use that.
Like I say,
Hey I have a home gym so I can just be alone in the giving of the cavern of doom
and just get after it,
don't me and I can be alone in my pain world of pain and proving myself and your
you did it cause you're too lazy to go to the gym.
Yeah.
To make that drive.
It's just more of a pain.
I can save some time.
Right.
Which it is an efficiency thing for sure.
Yeah.
That efficiency thing can convince them who you are.
It'll backfire.
Like for example,
I'll be like,
hey,
I don't have to,
you feel like you don't have to get the most study your workout because I can
just come right back here.
You know,
in an hour when I quote unquote feel better or when I feel more like doing it
or the TV's right there and lift a,
the
book big time.
It's a lack of discipline.
It can be.
And if you're looking for helpers for that discipline,
a home gym file,
it could go either way,
man.
I personally that I'm able to work out sometimes only because I have a home gym,
you know?
In other words,
if my time is in a day,
I'll get up super early and if I wouldn't be able to hit my own gym quickly,
you in 30 minutes and get a workout in,
I wouldn't be able to get,
it would take me 30 minutes to just get to gym and back.
Yeah.
Well I recommend if you make a home gym,
you do it in a positive way to increase your discipline.
That's what I recommend.
I like how you know your home gym is kind of separate from my house.
You have to kind of go
to it.
Yeah.
So I do get to escape.
Yeah,
I feel like that,
that's a big factor.
Mine is like right outside next to the barbecue next to the little,
you don't know whether you want to,
yeah,
I know about cruising or lifting,
you know,
so
she doesn't know if he's cruising or lifting.
Next question.
Okay.
Podcast question.
Uh,
how does it feel to do Tim Ferriss podcast,
Joe Rogan podcast and get thousands of followers,
listen to your podcast,
reading your book,
et Cetera.
Do you worry that some of your fans placed you on a pedestal and engage in hero
worship?
Yeah,
so this is a question that I was actually not going to do cause I was a little
bit uncomfortable with it and then I was like,
okay,
why are you uncomfortable with it?
It's not that big of a deal.
It,
although I will say like,
it does make me feel uncomfortable to think of people thinking of me in a heroic
way or whatever.
Uh,
that does feel strange to me.
as far as being on Rogan and Ferris and,
and Sam Harris and doing some of these podcasts,
uh,
it's,
you know,
it was,
it was really cool.
It's definitely,
uh,
you know,
people all the time as I travel and meeting people that have read,
read our book and,
and have gotten a lot out of it,
you know,
and that,
that feels very rewarding.
You know,
it feels very rewarding.
It feels great when someone says,
Hey,
you know,
I use this chapter or Hey,
your book.
I mean people are saying that like,
Hey,
your book changed my life and I take that with a grain of salt.
But it feels real.
It feels good.
It feels positive,
you know,
it feels,
I like that,
you know,
I want to help people and so that feels good.
But as far as,
it's not like my social media presence,
which I had zero before and now I have it and it's,
it's not really that big of a deal because it's just me.
Um,
I'm still just me and there's no,
there's nothing
that's different or has changed.
And when we talk about doing this podcast,
we don't talk about how we should act or how I should act to get more people to
listen to it.
I'm only doing what I'm doing because this is me and I'm not going to be
different in order to achieve anything else.
I'm only going to be who I am.
And that's why the font of people putting me on a pedestal or whatever,
that's
it.
I know that I'm just a person and,
and I think that it might be how,
okay,
how I get presented,
you know,
by the media,
how I get presented.
Even on this podcast,
when I'm on this podcast talking to you,
we're talking about specific subjects that we are interested in and it's not,
you know,
I could see where someone might think,
oh,
you know,
yeah.
Jack was the super,
you know,
super human and,
and no,
I know I'm not.
So if I come across like that,
it's only because you're seeing a,
a sliver of me that appears that way.
Right.
I'm not seeing him.
I know I'm not totally normal as well.
I mean,
I know I'm not a normal person.
I know him a little bit to the,
to the edge of,
you know,
being a little bit extreme.
Yeah.
A little bit extreme.
Yes.
In some ways.
Yeah.
And I know a lot of that just has to do with my habits as a person.
Uh,
but
okay.
The,
the fact of the matter is that no matter what happens and no matter what I come
across and,
and no matter what people might perceive me as,
I don't perceive myself as
special or as a hero for sure because [inaudible] one thing that will not,
that will always stay with me is that
I been in combat and I've been humbled by combat.
And I think that I've been on the battlefield and I've been confused and I've
been outmaneuvered and I've had my guys killed.
And so
I know what a real hero is and it ain't me.
And that's always good to keep me grounded and I will never forget that.
Yeah.
And you,
um,
as far as being worried about people putting you on a pedestal,
like how you're saying you just,
you be,
you,
and that's all you're going to do is be you.
You're not trying to live up to anyone's expectation.
That was never a goal of yours.
No.
So if someone has an expectation since that's not your goal,
how can you worry about it?
You're going to continue to be you.
And it was,
I think,
I don't know if it's irony,
but the more you do that and just be just authentic or whatever,
it seems to draw more people to you
I guess.
But I don't know because I'm not acting any other way that I acted a year ago or
you know,
four years ago,
I'm just,
you know what I do,
I train Jujitsu,
I work out,
I wake up early in the morning,
I try and get smarter.
I uh,
okay.
Try and do better.
Yeah.
That's what I do.
Uh,
so,
so yeah,
I'm just gonna,
you know,
I'm me and I actually,
I'll tell you,
this is interesting is that
okay.
People that I interact with now,
I enjoy it and I get something out of it.
I'm taking away their given me as much inspiration is I'm given them.
Yeah.
You know,
there's one girl on the,
on the,
on Twitter.
And I don't want to say her name cause I,
I mean it's a,
I don't know how,
I don't,
I don't like to disrupt people's privacy.
I mean,
she's on Twitter,
but she's,
uh,
clearly a little bit of an older lady.
She's um,
yeah,
she's a cancer survivor.
I mean,
when I say older,
I mean she's in her,
at least in her sixties and,
and she put a picture on the Internet the other day on Twitter of her at the gym
and she's got,
you know,
like a kettle bell,
um,
well medicine ball and an oxygen tank in the game cause she's,
because she's in there working out and she's,
yeah,
I gotta bring my oxygen tank because of what,
you know,
I don't know know specifically why,
but amen.
If she can bring an oxygen tank to the gym and get after it at age 65 or 70,
you don't,
that's inspiring.
And,
and I can get up and get after it and do my piece just,
you know,
just to at least just as well as as she could.
And,
and so I think that that's,
I think that's what's,
what's been interesting about this is seeing other people that are fired up and,
and you know,
that's,
that's another thing that kinda happened early on in this journey for me.
I have not a bunch of friends,
but one of my friends who's a seal,
when I was just about,
I think I had recorded the Tim Ferriss podcast and
I knew it was going to be released and I knew it was going to be heard by,
by people
in when,
when I did,
when I got back I,
I texted my friend and I said,
Hey,
uh,
I did this podcast and it's going to be released and
okay
I'm going to be one of them.
And when I meant by that was one of these guys that sold out for lack of a
better word.
Right.
And I'm out there,
you know,
on the navy seal and I'm the biggest,
baddest guy cause there's plenty of those guys out there now I'm going to be one
of those guys.
And so I said,
I said I'm going to be one of them now.
Sorry.
And he wrote me back and he said,
that's awesome.
And we got so many guys running around saying all kinds of stuff you should be
out there representing you should be.
And he went on to say something even more powerful.
And he said,
you know what?
There's a lot of people in this world that deed to role model that needed dad.
I needed a dad.
I needed a father figure and that's what you were for me.
And for you to go out there and be out there in the world and be that role model
for other people,
it's awesome and you should do it.
And I love the fact that you're doing it.
And when he wrote that to me,
it kind of changed my attitude because I did look at the role models that people
look at in,
I said to myself and,
and again
I think part of what might make me a good role models that I don't think I'm a
good role model because I'm still trying to get better and I've done all kinds
of stupid stuff.
We need to have a dozen podcasts on the stupid things I've done in my life and,
and talk about the mistakes I've made growing up and all the just,
I mean,
I'm,
that's another thing like when you would,
when people see me on the podcast over,
hear me on the podcast,
or they read the book,
they're seeing the good part right there,
seeing,
I would hesitate to say,
but they're seeing the best part of me.
They're seeing them mature person.
I'm not that mature,
but they're seeing that they're seeing the older,
the maturest that I've ever been,
which is right now they're not seeing the idiot,
you know,
growing dummy that I was in,
that many of us were when we were younger.
Now might I have had a little edge,
a little bit of advantage.
Maybe it was just a little bit ahead in some cases,
but man,
I didn't,
you know,
and so that when I got that tax,
that was a series of texts from,
uh,
from my brother,
that really gave me a different attitude on this whole thing.
And it made me feel more
comfortable with the fact that I was selling out and that I was now going to be
out there in the public view.
And,
and all this being said,
at some point I'm probably going to go right back to the cave that I came from
and um,
um,
I'm,
I don't want,
um,
you know,
I don't have what patent had,
which would just like this huge desire to be famous.
I have no problem not being,
I was an unrecognizable to the world
for my whole life.
And the fact that I'm a little bit recognizable now,
it doesn't make me feel great.
It doesn't do anything for me.
I'm just doing what I do.
It's not my goal.
But there,
is there a goal to try and help some people out there?
Yes.
And I think hearing that from that buddy of mine made me solidify that goal a
little bit.
And again,
not to try and say,
hey,
be like me.
No,
it's to say learn from what I learned from,
I did some dumb stuff.
I been through some stuff that most people don't have to go through.
So if you can take something away from it,
awesome.
You know,
don't worship me by any stretch,
but let's work together and see if we can get better as a team.
And you're a good,
like some,
a lot of your messages and the things that you say,
a lot of it is new and then a lot of it's not new.
Right?
So,
and so this is one point where in some of this stuff people may have heard
before,
but someone like you who's done what you've done and think the way you think and
do what you do right now,
you're the perfect medium for that,
for that information to get passed on to someone.
You know,
like,
you know when you're a teenager or something,
your dad tells you to do something to your mom telling you,
do you,
you're like,
how fucked up.
But then when you go and then you go to your friend's house and then like he
tells you to do it the exact same thing and you're like,
hey,
yeah.
You know,
it just,
it takes that same message,
but from someone who you can,
for lack of a better way of putting it,
someone you can accept it from.
And so all your messages are perfectly in line with who you are.
So there's still like,
you're so eager to accept them,
you know,
so like how you put online,
you'll post a picture of your watch every morning and you're kind of the workout
setting and stuff like that.
Um,
and you're kind of your message,
um,
more or less is get up every morning and get your work done,
get a workout in,
whatever,
and then you're doing it and there's the proof right there.
So if you're just some dude,
like,
yeah,
work out every day and you don't do it.
And it was like,
hey,
it's going to be harder,
harder to accept.
So people will get those messages and they'll,
they'll,
they'll internalize them way more readily from someone like you given the
messages that you're,
you're,
um,
you're sending,
that's one,
two,
the whole broadcasting yourself thing is,
is totally understandable for,
for someone like you in that,
that it's good that you kinda got your kind of got turned on to the notion that
it's more,
you have really good messages in good content that w improve people in their
life,
whether it be older people,
younger people,
girls,
guys,
everything.
And this is especially like a podcast situation or even like certain online
profiles and stuff.
They're good ways to get that information out that people need.
Men like to improve themselves.
Like A,
if you're in an,
in a,
in a neighborhood that we're in an environment with a bunch of people improving
themselves,
that's going to be a good neighborhood.
And if they have the means to improve themselves,
then that's us a good service that you're putting out there.
And,
and,
and to reach as many people as you do,
you're essentially,
you're helping the world with your message.
Okay.
I'm telling you.
See what I'm saying?
Broadcasting yourself is a good thing.
Yeah.
It definitely was a hard thing to,
to
overcome the,
the uh,
yeah,
the aversion.
Yeah.
To Broadcasting Yourself,
which is something I,
you know,
I talked about with Tim Ferris and I talked about it with Gi Joe Rogan is this
idea of people that are talking.
Yeah.
And you know,
you look at the extreme examples of social media,
you know,
abusers,
abusers and worthlessness.
Yeah.
You know,
and,
and you just don't want to have anything to do with them.
And when you're,
when you're doing it,
regardless of how much you don't want to have anything to do with them,
you have something to do with them because you're doing it too.
And it's very difficult for me not to feel like that.
Now obviously I've gotten over it.
I mean,
I,
I've gotten over it to a point where I'm saying,
okay,
these are kind of the acceptable parameters that I operate within for my
personality.
Right.
You know,
which is,
there's things that I haven't done and I won't do on social media.
Right.
You know?
Yeah.
Because I'm not there to promote me.
Um,
uh,
but I'm there to only open the door of observation.
I would say not to,
not to knock on people's door and enter,
but just to open the door of observation and say,
this is how I try to live and this is the steps that I take to try and live that
way.
Observe and,
and if you want to enter my house and hang out with me,
come on in.
Yeah.
As long as you're likeminded and,
and you have the same sort of goals,
then come on in and,
and you know what?
You're going to make me stronger.
Yeah.
You're going to bolster me up your ice.
So many people now they're posting pictures of their watches on my Twitter.
Yeah.
When I wake up,
I'm looking at 50 to a hundred watches every day and I'm going,
wow,
that's a lot of people.
And that is unity.
And that is leadership.
And it does make me feel like,
okay,
cool.
There's other people in the world that are up and getting after it.
Yeah.
It Day 20.
And there,
there was a guy who's a teacher posts good.
He's a teacher here,
posted good on his classroom door in his classroom door man.
And so now he's,
yeah,
I'm kind of pushing that,
those good messages to the kids,
you know?
Yeah.
So,
yeah,
I mean it's all,
I think it's all positive social media.
It easy to get
to get that attitude towards it because of all the people who will abuse it,
quote unquote.
But you know,
like if you went,
I don't know,
like on the highway and all you saw was people speeding,
reckless driving,
it still doesn't change the fact that you still want to drive on highway because
you have something to do.
You know,
your,
your pursuit is different.
But yeah,
there's going to be everyone.
The other weird thing is I have no idea where this is going,
you know?
And so like this podcast,
I didn't,
you know,
we just kinda did it.
I went on with Tim Ferriss,
so just kind of did it.
I started Twitter.
I had no idea what that was going to be.
Yeah.
And so it's,
it's fun for me to be adventuring into things that I don't know the outcome of.
This is one of them and Twitter is one of them.
The book was one of them and you know,
I don't know what's around the corner next and I don't know where this is going,
but I will stay with the principles that I believe in
to the best of my ability.
And I think that's what makes it an interesting ride.
Where's that going?
Go?
Yeah,
we'll find out.
Okay,
last question Jocko.
What motivates you?
I heard you mentioned the man in the cave.
Can you go deeper on this?
What motivates me?
Well,
I've talked about this before and it's kind of what we were talking about a
couple of minutes ago as well.
And that is first of all with the man in the cave and this idea and this thought
of the enemy.
And that was a thought that used to drive me and kind of haunt me and make me
get up early and work hard to push myself because I knew
that somewhere out there there was an enemy,
a real enemy,
a real man,
a person,
a human
that was waiting for me and that was preparing for me and therefore I needed
to prepare for him.
I needed to be ready.
I needed to be the things I always talk about.
I needed to be stronger and faster and smarter and better
so that when we did meet on the battlefield,
I would be ready for that run.
Dayvoo for that meeting,
that fate,
that battle,
and that thought,
that thought of the enemy.
It,
yes,
it absolutely
fueled me.
It,
and when I was a leader in the seal teams,
in charge of men,
it was even more profound
because I was thinking about that rendezvous
for everybody,
that I led everyone else in charge of everyone that I trained.
And I felt that burden,
the burden of responsibility
to prepare those men and protect those bowls.
Men,
those those frog men was warriors,
my brothers.
And it,
it was my burden to train those guys and prepared them.
And that burden,
it may have made me a little bit crazy,
a little bit paranoid,
a little bit over the top,
but
I didn't really know any,
any other way.
And
so now
I am no longer
a combat leader.
I no longer prepare men for war.
So the drive
and the motivation,
it's from a different place.
It's from a solemn place,
the drive now when the motivation now is
not really from the enemy anymore,
now it's from my friends,
my brothers.
It's from
those seals
that I knew
and that I
cared about more than anything.
And that they sacrificed
everything
for us and for me and those guys.
They gave their lives for us.
And now
I cannot help but think and remember that every breath that we take is a,
it's a gift.
It's a sacred gift from those men.
Every day we have every sunrise,
every thought,
and every smile and every laugh.
It's a gift.
And I will treasure that gift,
that gift of life.
And I will not let it go to waste.
Not One second of it,
and I will cherish every moment of it and I will live it.
I will live
it
in their memory
in their honor.
I think that's a,
that's about it for the night.
So
as always,
thank you for listening.
Thanks for subscribing.
Thanks for reviewing.
Thanks for supporting
and thanks for taking a moment
to remember the brave men and women
that have fought and died for our freedoms
and in their memory.
Make sure you get out there
and you get after.
Until next time,
this is echo and Jocko out.